should we do a little sync my ink hell
yeah I better get tatted up Thursday are
you really yeah
I saw you looking for I gotta get a tat
dude I got the guy here's Eddie Bravo he
looks like Eddie Bravo with my hair
Theo's forehead like Eddie Bravo dude
first of all the king of sting you
flatterer
what's a king of singing you [ __ ]
rare youtube links hey King you're
singing well beat by you want the smooth
a bit great line by the way thank you
yes
yeah great tattoos man does anybody get
straight mom i straight mom I'm confused
straight mom was where was it I was calf
was there rumor as mom wasn't straight
in the town straight mom's straight
mommy straight mom straight mom his calf
he was cast over mom mom upside down is
Wow
straight mom that's a confusing one
he said he's like a walking dad joke of
tattoos so like there's something there
about straight mom st ra IG HT m om
straight mom is that he spell straight
mm-hmm yeah I know it was you're waiting
for the answer to bring the big toes
like it's just great mom I don't know
what that is
straight mom mmm on his calf funniest
ones the hamstring and the piggy I'm
with the hamstrings got a straight mom
and then the camel atoll Kemp camel toe
yeah camel toes great that hamstrings
unbelievable not the best artwork in the
Caribbeans you know well you got lemon
yeah a lot of artists down there are two
città probably on the run from stuff I
mean once you get down to the islands
Key West Caribbean I mean you can't eat
the Caribbean is great unless you want
something then you have to wait forever
to get it like I remember trying to get
a fish dinner over there and uh and they
had to go wake the man up they put us in
the restaurant way to sit in there for
40 minutes went got the chef then they
come back I'll in life those two hours
and ten minutes for we age you ever been
in Costa Rica Costa Rica huh you're
burning Costa Rica yeah filled with
[ __ ] is it oh dude I walked into bars
just [ __ ] island you'd love in it never
had it was like a shark frenzy just
grabbing my dick yeah it was terrible
[Laughter]
over this guy's issue prostitution is
legal in Costa Rica that's why Brendon
it's not even some would say it's the
funnest time there you go on a crocodile
tour
do you dick suck in a crocodile tour
that's living brother then go ziplining
no naked
no dude Costa Rica's living you need to
get your mind out of the gutter brother
you need to get to church man and get
your act together you're right
I like that guys tats what's this way
great tats man we're gonna be thing
about the straight mom for the rest of
the month yeah
[Music]